Trascrizione: Silvia Fornasiero
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
[Musica]
Siete mai andati in vacanza,
una volta nella vostra vita? Una?
Io ci sono andato poche volte
e l'ultima, se non sbaglio,
è stata a maggio di quest'anno.
Sono andato a Madrid.
È successa una cosa curiosa a Madrid.
Come in tutte le grandi città --
anzi, non solo le grandi città --
come in tutte le città del mondo,
c'è un fenomeno che conosciamo
che è quello delle persone
che chiedono la carità,
le persone che fanno
i mendicanti, diciamo.
E qual è il sistema comunicativo
che utilizzano i mendicanti
per chiederci i soldi?
Non sto parlando
di una questione sociale, capitemi.
Sto parlando
di un sistema di comunicazione.
Fanno leva sostanzialmente
su due cose:
la prima è il nostro senso di colpa.
Ci troviamo in una strada ricca,
piena di negozi
e loro sono persone
che hanno problemi,
hanno dei problemi anche fisici
che ci mostrano.
Pensateci, ci sono delle persone
che mostrano i deficit fisici
per chiedere la nostra carità;
quindi fanno effetto
al nostro senso di colpa
e fanno effetto sulla nostra carità.
Persone che non hanno gambe,
non hanno le mani
e ci chiedono i soldi.
E noi quindi sappiamo oggettivamente
che hanno bisogno.
Non lo supponiamo,
lo sappiamo
ma non gli diamo i soldi.
Perché?
Mettiamo generalmente in atto
tre protezioni:
la prima è "Io glieli darei,
però se li dò a lui, li devo dare a tutti:
non posso uscire con 100 euro
la mattina per darli a tutti".
La seconda è: "Io glieli darei,
ma dietro c'è un racket;
se li dò a lui
poi il suo aguzzino glieli prende
e rimanda questa persona
a fare la carità".
La terza è: "Questa persona
potrebbe andare a lavorare
ha due spalle così, in campagna
a pomodori c'è sempre bisogno".
E non glieli dai.
A Madrid stavo camminando
su una strada che si chiama Gran Via --
chi è stato in Spagna la conosce --
una strada notevolmente ricca,
bella, raffinata, piena di negozi.
Ho visto un clochard,
per terra, seduto,
che non faceva assolutamente nulla
e ho visto le persone
che gli davano i soldi.
Io mi sono avvicinato
e ho continuato a vedere
persone dargli soldi
e lui non faceva nulla.
Allora ho pensato: questo
è il sacro Graal della comunicazione.
Se io capisco cosa sta facendo lui,
io divento ricco senza far nulla.
(Risate)
Mi sono avvicinato.
Mentre mi avvicinavo,
un ragazzo addirittura non solo
gli ha dato i soldi --
giuro ho visto con i miei occhi,
ero con la mia compagna --
gli ha dato i soldi, ha sorriso
e gli ha dato la mano prima di andar via.
Io non ho capito niente nella vita.
Avvicinandomi ho notato che aveva
una cosa semplice, banale quasi,
aveva davanti a sé
tre bussolotti, tre scatole.
In una c'era scritto:
quello che mettete qua va in birra;
quello che mettete qua va in vino;
quello che mettete qua va in whisky.
State ridendo tutti;
io ho riso uguale.
Ho detto: "Che figata questa qua!
Ma sai che io adesso
una bella birra me la farei?"
Ho dato i soldi per comprarsi la birra,
di fatto ammazzandolo,
perché se lui fa davvero quello che dice
che farebbe con quei soldi
io lo sto ammalando di cirrosi.
Allora ho cominciato a riflettere.
Ho cominciato a riflettere con forza
su questo fatto:
ma perché gli ho dato i soldi?
Perché a gente senza gambe
non glieli do
e metto in atto dei meccanismi
e a lui glieli ho dati.
Poi ho capito.
Ogni volta che noi facciamo qualcosa,
lo facciamo per noi.
Non lo facciamo per gli altri.
Lo facciamo per noi
e anche per gli altri.
Ogni volta che facciamo del bene
ed è meraviglioso,
lo facciamo perché
ci fa stare bene.
E fa anche stare bene gli altri.
E a questo aggiungo:
lui, il clochard, non mi ha chiesto nulla.
Era seduto e mi ha fatto ridere,
mi ha dato qualcosa, non mi ha chiesto.
Mi ha fatto ridere,
mi ha dato un imprinting positivo,
una percezione positiva.
E quindi, visto che non mi ha chiesto,
io gli ho dato.
"Se questa cosa, arrivato a 44 anni,
non l'avevo mai pensata prima" ho pensato,
"quante sono le on-line
che ci capitano tutti i giorni
e che noi non siamo in grado di valutare."
Il mondo dell'on-line
non c'era 10 anni fa.
La vita on-line è ormai comune per tutti,
non si può neanche più dire
che vado on-line,
noi siamo on-line costantemente.
Un italiano usa Google
30 volte al giorno mediamente.
Un Millennial guarda il telefono
250 volte al giorno, senza notifiche.
Provate a immaginare
quante volte lo guarda con le notifiche.
Quindi è evidente
che accadono cose on-line
che noi non siamo in grado di interpretare
perché 10 anni fa non c'erano.
Mancano regole educative comuni.
Vi faccio un esempio su tutti.
Avete mai sentito di questa parola
che ho messo in inglese
perché in ferrarese non si può sentire?
(Risate)
Quando dico "Disibinizione on-line"
la gente mi guarda e mi dice: "Dai...".
On-line disinibisce. Di fatto,
si tratta di questo:
le persone tendono a fare --
alcune persone, non tutte --
tendono a fare di più e più spesso
on-line piuttosto che off-line.
E se questo vale un po' per tutti,
c'è un altro fenomeno legato a questo
particolare concetto, che è curioso.
Quando noi discutiamo
con qualcuno off-line,
attacchiamo qualcuno off-line,
ne soffriamo,
soffriamo stress nell'attaccare qualcuno.
Quando questo accade on-line, no.
Ma se veniamo attaccati off-line,
subiamo uno stress;
se veniamo attaccati on-line,
subiamo uno stress.
Quindi vedete che c'è
una differenza sostanziale:
ecco perché c'è
il fenomeno degli haters.
Ecco perché alcune persone
molto in vista in Italia sui social,
donne in particolare, vengono attaccate
con frasi di una brutalità
e di una violenza,
che nella vita reale non esisterebbero.
Non è l'impunità;
è questo fenomeno.
Siamo in un mondo nuovo.
È un fatto.
E non importa cosa ne pensate.
E in un mondo nuovo
c'è bisogno di regole nuove.
C'è bisogno di regole nuove
perché noi non siamo
in grado di interpretare
quello che ci accade di fianco,
quello che ci accade attorno.
Che cosa sta succedendo?
Quindi io mi sono trovato a pensare:
prima ho bisogno di un assioma.
Ho bisogno di una macro regola,
come la relatività di Einstein,
che metta d'accordo ogni tipo di cosa,
ogni tipo di attività, contenuto,
persona, evento che accade on-line.
Nella mia ricerca mi sono imbattuto
in un libro, che consiglio a tutti
perché è incredibilmente bello,
che si chiama "In un milione
di piccoli pezzi" di James Frey.
Tratta di un ragazzo che esce dal tunnel
di tutte le dipendenze
che esistono su questa terra,
facendo uno sforzo immane.
Vi voglio raccontare di questa frase
incredibile che ho letto in questo libro
che è: "Curati di quanto dicono gli altri
e sarai sempre loro prigioniero".
Io, quando l'ho letta, ho pensato:
ho trovato il mantra.
Io non posso curarmi
di quello che dicono gli altri
altrimenti divento
quello che gli altri vogliono.
Se comincio a sbattermene di quello
che gli altri dicono di me on-line,
sono un uomo libero.
Contemporaneamente, ho trovato
questa frase di Siegmund --
non ripeto il cognome perché tanto
non ce la farei mai, sputerei.
Evidentemente gli psicologi tedeschi
si chiamano tutti così.
La frase, ragazzi, è incredibile:
"La vita umana
si è sempre svolta in gruppi",
la leggo perché non voglio sbagliare,
"Condividere costituisce un elemento
essenziale dell'esperienza:
nessuna salute mentale
è compatibile senza di questo".
Non possiamo non curarci degli altri,
perché se no non siamo sani di mente.
Allora vedete che andiamo
in cortocircuito.
Abbiamo detto:
bellissima la frase di Frei
"Per essere libero
non me ne devo curare",
ma non posso non curarmene.
Ma allora, che cosa devo fare?
Devo ascoltare tutto quello
che mi viene detto e devo somatizzarlo
o non devo ascoltare nessuno?
Voi riconoscerete in questa foto
una persona che lava una macchina.
Bello, no?
Tre anni fa ho avuto
un incidente in auto;
un camion per i trasporti eccezionali
mi ha investito; è la verità.
Non mi sono fatto nulla ma la macchina
si è completamente distrutta.
Allora, il giorno dopo, sui social,
ho fatto una provocazione ironica.
Ho scritto un post nel quale dicevo:
quest'anno ho scritto il mio primo libro,
sto bene in giacca,
ho presentato degli eventi fichissimi,
ho fatto il Giro d'Italia.
Tutte cazzate di questo tipo
e alla fine ho scritto: non è possibile
che non esista una casa automobilistica
che non mi regali una macchina.
Non è giusto.
È il primo esperimento italiano
di crowdfunding personale,
detto anche scroccaggio.
(Applausi)
La mattina dopo,
con mio assoluto sconcerto,
mi chiama una casa automobilistica
e mi dicono:
"Abbiamo sentito,
abbiamo letto il suo messaggio,
vorremmo regalarle una macchina."
Io al telefono ho risposto:
"E la fregatura dove sta? Cosa devo fare?
Cioè, mi date anche delle pentole
da pagare ... come funziona?"
Mi danno un'auto e ovviamente
il mondo del web --
un'auto con un hashtag sulla fiancata
'Una macchina per Rudy';
infatti le persone mi chiedevano:
"Ma chi è Rudy?
Una persona con dei problemi?"
No, sono io.
(Risate)
Si, è una persona
con dei problemi, in effetti.
Il web italiano si è spaccato.
Da una parte quelli che dicevano:
"Rudy Bandiera è un genio".
Dall'altra parte quelli
che dicevano:
"Rudy Bandiera è un matto".
Dall'altra parte quelli
che dicevano: "Rudy Bandiera è un ladro
perché questa macchina
l'avrebbero potuta dare a una onlus
invece di darla a lui".
C'era gente che diceva:
"Rudy Bandiera è ricco,
se la doveva comprare".
Mia moglie leggeva
queste cose e diceva:
"Ma davvero sei ricco?"
Ve lo giuro!
Gente che diceva
brutalità tremende nei miei confronti.
Io mi sono trovato una sera,
non sto scherzando, a piangere.
Ho 44 anni. A piangere per quello
che gente mi diceva senza conoscermi.
Allora ho riflettuto: ma perché?
Perché mi giudicavano.
Non giudicavano il fatto; giudicavano me.
Senza conoscermi.
Allora lì ho capito tutto.
Ho capito che io devo ascoltare
tutto quello che dicono gli altri
quando il motore da cui sono mossi
non è il risentimento,
non è la rabbia, non è l'invidia
e non è il giudizio.
Noi non possiamo giudicare
quello che non conosciamo.
Possono dire: "Rudy Bandiera
ha fatto una bellissima cosa".
ha fatto una bruttissima cosa".
Possono dire: "Sa parlare. Non sa parlare.
È furbo. È intelligente.
È brutto. Ha la barba ispida",
ma non possono giudicarmi come individuo.
Questo è il primo assioma: dobbiamo
ascoltare tutti coloro che non giudicano.
Perché on-line è facilissimo
puntare il dito e giudicare.
È facilissimo e noi dobbiamo
liberarci da questa cosa.
Oltre all'assioma,
ho pensato a sette regole
e siccome sono un genio creativo,
le ho chiamate Le Sette Regole.
(Risate)
Avevo pensato di chiamarle
Le Otto Regole e di metterne sette.
Allora lì si che sarei stato
davvero brillante.
Ma mi sembrava già sufficiente
fare questa idiozia.
L'assioma l'abbiamo capito:
il giudizio è il problema.
Le regole sono queste.
Regola numero uno, ragazzi,
il mezzo è contenuto.
Sempre di più e lo sarà sempre di più.
Noi siamo quello
che gli altri percepiscono,
quindi noi siamo quello che comunichiamo.
Non credete a chi vi dice:
"L'abito non fa il monaco".
Lo fa, dannatamente.
Il vincere sempre, a tutti i costi,
non è essere vincenti, è essere arroganti.
Non dobbiamo umiliare le persone
con le quali comunichiamo su Facebook,
Tweeter, Linkedin per vincere
in una discussione.
Vincere solo, vincere sempre è arrogante.
Devi stare lucido e concentrato
su chi hai di fronte.
Pensate a Skype. Quante volte
vi è successo di fare delle call-Skype.
Quante volte sentite quello dall'altra
parte che scrive sulla tastiera.
Fa incazzare da morire.
Stai parlando con me
o stai parlando con qualcun altro?
Lucidi e concentrati
sulla persona che avete di fronte.
In quel momento è la persona
più importante della vostra esistenza.
Non devi calpestare B per andare da A a C.
Oggi mettiamo tutto
sul piatto del risultato.
Se ho un risultato sono bravo. Non è vero.
Se hai fatto un percorso dignitoso,
non umiliante per nessuno
che ti ha portato un risultato, sei bravo.
Se no sei un perdente.
Dobbiamo riprendere in mano
il discorso delle brave persone.
Dobbiamo far tornare di moda
l'essere brave persone.
Chi se ne frega dei risultati da soli.
Viviamo in un mondo
con altre persone.
Non è il mio risultato
che migliora tutto il resto,
è il percorso che ho fatto
per raggiungerlo.
Non sei obbligato a partecipare
a tutte le discussioni.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
La settimana scorsa
ho trovato uno che ha scritto:
"Quello che penso io
vale quello che pensi tu".
Ma chi l'ha detto?
(Risate)
Se si sta parlando di social
e di tecnologia e tu fai il chirurgo,
scusa, ma il tuo giudizio
non è come il mio.
Se si sta parlando di medicina,
tu fai il chirurgo e io faccio il muratore
il mio giudizio non è come il tuo.
Non devi per forza dire la tua!
Ascolta, stai zitto ogni tanto.
Hai una responsabilità verso tutti.
Ragazzi, noi dobbiamo individuare
nella nostra testa quest'immagine:
se tu andavi nel bar e dicevi una cazzata
la gente attorno ti diceva: "Taci!"
Ti pagavano una spuma
e ti mandavano a casa.
Oggi non è più così.
Tu puoi influenzare migliaia di individui
ogni giorno della tua vita.
Devi esserne responsabile.
Non deve esserne responsabile
la piattaforma; tu sei responsabile.
Sei sempre in pubblico,
anche quando sei in privato.
Capita sempre più spesso
che le conversazioni private
arrivino in pubblico.
È una cosa per nulla da sottovalutare.
Le comunicazioni che avvengono on-line,
sempre più spesso avvengono
in canali privati, gruppi chiusi,
gruppi segreti, chat.
Voi dovete pensare che quello
che scrivete qui, può uscire.
Non è bello, non è giusto,
ma può accadere.
Guardate tutti i casi di cyber-bullismo,
ma anche i casi delle banche
che sono capitati ultimamente.
I dati sono nostri, sono importantissimi,
ma fate molta attenzione a quello
che scrivete, anche se in privato.
E poi ho fatto una considerazione
che secondo me è piuttosto interessante
che è questa -- l'ho chiamata
'La Teoria delle Cerchie Ristrette'
perché mi piace dire
che costruisco delle teorie.
Non importa quello che fai
o cosa sei diventato,
non importa
come ti vedono gli altri:
i tuoi amici di vecchia data ti vedranno
sempre e comunque come il solito pirla.
Con amore, benevolenza
e dolcezza, ma un pirla.
Io ho scritto tre libri;
l'ultimo l'ho scritto con la casa editrice
più importante d'Italia.
Mia moglie non ha letto
nessuno dei miei libri.
(Risate)
Li ha sul comodino, eh!
C'è stata una volta che le ho chiesto:
"Ma ti fan schifo? Perché non li leggi?"
Mi ha detto: "Ma dai, ti conosco
da una vita, siamo insieme da una vita,
sto con te, lo so che cosa pensi."
I miei amici con cui faccio aperitivo
tutti i venerdì sera,
lo faccio da vent'anni
alcuni li conosco da trent'anni,
hanno tutti i miei libri,
nessuno ne ha letto uno.
(Risate)
Allora io mi sono chiesto: perché?
Ho cominciato a chiedere a loro
e loro hanno cominciato a dirmi:
"Ma si dai, ma dai".
Fine della risposta.
Sapete il motivo? Il motivo è semplice.
Per loro Rudi Bandiera
è quello delle grigliate,
è quello delle sbronze al venerdì sera,
è quello del "Dai, andiamo
a mangiare il pesce al mare",
è quello del "Dai, facciamo un LANparty
domenica a quarant'anni".
Rudi Bandiera è quello che fa da sempre
queste cose con loro.
Quindi, io vi voglio lasciare
con tre riflessioni molto semplici.
Date, come il clochard di Madrid,
sul web date informazioni utili,
oggettive, funzionali.
Ricordate di occuparvi di quello che
dicono gli altri solo se non vi giudicano
e rimanete per i vostri amici
degli amabili pirla.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
E adesso farò un selfie,
quindi vi prego sorridete,
siate felici, evviva!
Grazie, vi voglio bene.